hello there today we're looking at a
path towards autonomous machine
intelligence by young laka also called
the japa paper actually
i think only i call it the japa paper
but japa is a new architecture that jan
laca proposes as a part of this paper
and we're gonna go into it as he himself
describes it as the corner piece of this
method so you will learn what one of the
godfathers and touring award winners
thinks of how we should reach machine
intelligence or at least one proposal of
it the abstract reads how could machines
learn as efficiently as humans and
animals how could machines learn to
reason and plan how cut machines learn
representations of percepts and action
plans at multiple levels of abstraction
enabling them to reason predict and plan
at multiple time horizons these things
are largely all open problems in current
deep learning uh efficient learning
especially deep learning is notoriously
data hungry uh reasoning and planning is
something that a lot of these things
can't do at least according to some
people and uh certainly reasoning
predicting planning at multiple time
horizons these kind of things including
abstraction all of these things are
still sort of out of the realm of
current deep learning so here is ian
lacaze
position paper as he calls it of how to
reach these things
so he also says the text is written with
as little jargon as possible and using
as little mathematical prior knowledge
as possible so as to appeal to readers
with a wide variety of backgrounds now i
don't want to actually go through the
whole paper because the whole paper is
what 69 pages long or so but i'll
present to you sort of the core piece
which is the jep architecture and just a
little bit around that so you know
what's going on and i think it's pretty
cool
here he states the main contributions of
the paper are the following first an
overall cognitive architecture in which
all modules are differentiable and many
of them are trainable this is going to
be one of the more wishy-washy hand-wavy
pieces of the paper we'll quickly look
at it then japa and hierarchical japa a
non-generative architecture for
predictive world models that learn a
hierarchy of representations
so there should immediately you should
see that you have a non-generative
architecture but for predictive world
models which is going to be interesting
how can you be non-generative yet still
predict stuff we're going to see that in
fact the predictions happen in the
latent space kind of like
mu zero if you will
third a non-contrastive non-contrastive
self-supervised learning paradigm that
produces representations that are
simultaneously informative and
predictable
and the key thing here is going to be
this non-contrastive part
le com makes a big deal out of
out of
pitching essentially pitting contrastive
and non-contrastive methods and arguing
why non-contrastive methods should be
preferred above contrastive methods
mostly due to the curse of
dimensionality
lastly a way to use h geppa at the basis
of predictive world models for
hierarchical planning under uncertainty
so the age here is going to be for the
hierarchical extension or the
hierarchical hierarchical arrangement of
the jepa architecture
he says impatient readers may prefer to
jump directly to the aforementioned
sections will do exactly that
so there is a bit about world models and
and why it's important and here is kind
of the
entire proposed architecture now as i
said this is a little bit hand wavy uh
so there is essentially a world model
which is you know pretty important and
that's going to be the center piece
right here that predicts the state of
the world forward in time so this is the
actual world and the world model is
trying to predict that it's going to
interact with this actor module right
here obviously the actor is going to be
what actually does the action however
the actor could also act inside of the
world model in sort of a simulated
reality and and plan forward what would
happen if i were to do something or it
could interact with the world model to
find the best action to do and that's
exactly what we're going to see
the short term memory here is going to
be used to train that world model and
also to train that critic so it's
essentially the things that happen in
the world are going to be stored into
the short-term memory and then the
critic can be updated from that but will
not look into that very well very much
perception module right here is a module
that takes the whatever the world gives
and makes it available as a
representation or as a perception this
is going to be the let's say the entry
point to the systems that we have and
this is very much
the closest that we have to something
master module that configures all the
other modules uh depending on what
situation they're in and so on and this
is is definitely like there's a lot of
hand waving right here it's like yeah
yeah we can just have like a top down
configurator that configures stuff
and i don't wanna i don't wanna go too
much into it because there's not too
much to go into but also it's not the
core of the paper we're gonna go what
we're going to go into the world model
here specifically
so
first of all he describes a two
different ways of let's say acting in
the world and here we are for the first
time introduced to kind of like the
notation of this paper which is very
much in diagrams uh so this is what he
calls a mode one perception action
episode this goes very much uh with like
conomon i believe it was kanema like
mode 1 and mode 2
reasoning or thinking so mode one is
sort of reactive you simply go from
perception of the world to action
without much thought uh it's kind of
subconscious and this is encapsulated
here so we start with the world we get
like some sort of so sort of observation
we put this through the encoder right
here that's going to give us a latent
representation this encoder is that that
perception perception
module that we saw before now
different things happen but only
actually one path is critical namely
this goes to the actor right here this
is the actor
and the actor sends back an action to
the world
as you can see this is a straightforward
signal routing to the actor and back oh
it even says actor right here
it says even this reactive process does
not make use of the world model nor the
cost so there is a cost module that we
saw which tells sort of how much
something is whether it's good or bad
this can be intrinsic motivation this
can be external reward anything like
this we can compute it however in this
very basic loop the actor has been
trained already to just act on a percept
at inference time the actor doesn't need
to look at the cost anymore in order to
act this is what we're very used to from
current like
model 3 reinforcement learning
algorithms they simply train the actor
using the reward but then once it's
inference time they simply let the actor
act and rely on that training this is
one of this is a mode 1 perception
action episode in contrast to that
we are introduced to the mode 2
perception action episode this is a
little bit more involved you can see
here that we are rolling out the world
model forward in order to do something
and what do we do again we have an input
here we go through the encoder this is
probably a wrong color as it's the same
uh we go through the encoder however now
we are going to roll out the world model
across different time steps and how are
we going to roll out the world model
we're going to use the actor right here
so the actor is going to take that state
it gets from the encoder and propose an
action this is the same actor as before
it's just sort of a trained thing that's
proposing some action okay
good enough we can use that into the
world model together with the latent
prediction you
realize right here the predictor here
this thing it takes whatever comes out
of the encoder right here that means it
takes a latent state of the world and it
predicts the next latent state of the
world that's why he calls this
non-generative
these these world models and and these
encoders they all go to latent space and
then they predict stuff in latent space
so in fact it doesn't predict the world
it predicts the latent state of the
world which enables it to focus on
what's truly important for the task
obviously modulo how well you can train
this thing
to to actually do that
and how you can prevent it from collapse
we'll get to all of that
however you'll notice that
now we can give the actor the
representation it proposes an action we
can
actually use the world model to predict
the next state from that next state we
can ask the actor for an action the
actor gives us an action and we can
predict the next state now what does
that give us
in fact that gives us
quite a bit let's let's assume let's
just assume
that
episodes are always the same length and
forget about this forget about this
forget about this episodes are always
the same length this length right here
and you won't get any reward or anything
or any intrinsic reward until the very
end like until the very end there's kind
of like a a reward or a cost or
something like this well we can compute
it which is fine we could already do
that before it's informative but we
didn't do anything with it however once
we have that whole loop done if all of
these things are differentiable what we
can do is we can say well this action
sequence right here right now would give
us like a reward of five okay can we
make that bigger well since everything's
differentiable i can certainly use back
propagation and gradient descent to ask
how would this action need to change in
order to make this thing go higher right
maybe i need to switch to a different
action now it's six well can i also
change that action to make it go higher
oh well i can now it's seven and so on
so i can modify i can optimize all of
these actions at inference time using
gradient descent
right this is if this is not familiar to
you it's kind of the same as if you
construct an adversarial example to an
image classifier that's also gradient
descent at inference time so here
gradient descent isn't used to train any
of these modules we assume that training
is done gradient descent is used in
order to improve this initial action
sequence to a more optimal set of
actions and we do that you know we
improve these actions here we're using
gradient descent through all these
modules
until we have completely optimized the
action sequence and which means that
this very first action
is
probably very good action like hopefully
a better action than was first proposed
by the naive actor and then we can take
that action
and feed it to the world as an action so
this is mode to uh perception action
episode this is kind of the model
thinking about the future and figuring
out through forward-looking what do i
need to do what do i need to change to
improve the outcome uh how can i how can
i make stuff better and that necessarily
uses this world model right
and obviously this is just more general
if you include all of these costs which
you can have after every step
you can include
some kind of discount factors and yada
yada yada
um yeah so
inference time optimization isn't new
but it is sort of how lacan sees
a way one way of how to make these
things plan forward
so the text says through an optimization
or search procedure the actor infers a
sequence of actions that minimizes the
total energy so these things are called
energy and note that it doesn't
necessarily need to be optimization it
could also be search it could be
evolutionary search it could be tree
search
anything that actually
tries to improve the action sequence at
inference time
an instance of classical model
predictive control this is an instance
of classical model predictive control
with reseeding horizon planning
all right
and
this here is how we would train such a
thing so not such a thing sorry let's
assume that
we have the two modes we have this naive
actor and we use the naive actor to
propose
sequences for the
uh longer like for for this thing right
we propose the first sequence using the
naive actor
in
mode one mode two language there is such
a thing as if you do
something often
and you do it consciously at some point
it becomes subconscious right like
muscle memory or something like this
well how could this work
this is how this could work in this
framework so you'd have
uh essentially these actions right here
are the ones that we have come up
through this whole planning process
through this whole optimization process
well what you can do is you can simply
ask the actor
or take that output from the initial
actor and then you can try to make these
things as close as possible right you
have all the things right here
everything's differentiable so you can
train the actor to essentially match
those better actions
because you know the actor would propose
one action however this other action you
found to be superior using your world
model now obviously that requires you to
have a good world model but if you have
that then you can improve this low level
actor and at some point that initial
action sequence that it proposes will
already be close to optimal it's kind of
an approximation that you distill into
this actor
so this is
first introduction to the system right
here we're going to look a little bit
more
into
how these systems should actually work
and here starts a discussion of two
things the first one is self-supervised
learning
and the second one is energy-based
models the first one is sort of a
training paradigm of how to train
models
using unsupervised data the second one
is i want to say
a way of thinking about these models
it's a formulation of a system
and we'll get to it and they are
connected
so
self-supervised learning le con sees
this in the following terms i have a
piece of data which is this whole block
right here and i try to
predict i try to like mask out the piece
which is this right hand side right here
like i pretend i don't know it and then
i use the thing i do know
and i try to predict the thing i don't
know
it's not exactly that however
in fact what i
want to do is i don't want to predict
the thing i don't know i want to create
this thing called an energy function an
energy function
tells me how well
these two things fit together
and this is going to become clearer in
just a second but the way it's
formulated right here is that to capture
the dependencies between the observed
parts of the input and possibly
unobserved parts of the input
so
this
is supposed to
well
it's gonna as i said it's gonna get
clearer in just one second but what you
want to do is you want to train a system
that sees the data space in this format
right here which is going to be a
so-called energy landscape
so if you have imagine this is a video
sequence right here so there is a bunch
of frames and a bunch of frames and
frames frames frames frames frames right
here
so
if you have this energy landscape right
here you're trying to relate
first like the start of a video sequence
to the end of a video sequence
you can imagine this in a very high
dimensional space essentially where
all the frames here are concatenated to
to a big vector and all the frames here
as well
and the energy function or the system
that you train should assign a very low
energy to all of the video sequences
that are let's say realistic
or
in other words here is an x whenever x
is this video sequence then
and why is this video sequence
then the energy function should assign a
low energy to that if the two could
actually follow e one another so if y
could follow x
if y would be a logical continuation of
x in video space the energy function
should assign a low value to that this
formulation is very cool because it
means if we don't need to predict y from
x directly because there could be
multiple video sequences right following
that same beginning and
that means if we were to just predict
why then we would
probably train the system i mean we can
still do it but we can probably we will
probably train the system to say no
there is one correct continuation
however if we train the energy function
the energy function could assign a low
value to any possible continuation as
long as it assigns a high value
everywhere else we're good so we're
trying to
produce systems that behave like this
now i for i used to think energy
function and training loss are the same
thing but i know that young lacan is
very adamant about the thing that an
energy function is sometime something
that you minimize at inference time
while the training loss is something
that you minimize at training time
sometimes they are very
similar and overlapping for example a
lot of times uh the the um
energy function and the training loss
are the same formula
and by training the system you
actually immediately cause it to
minimize that energy at inference time
simply by forward passing in the model
however we can do more with energy
functions which we're going to see right
now
now we introduce latent variable
energy-based models
this is the same formulation as before
we have an x and a y and we have an
energy function that tells us how well
those two are compatible with each other
which is going to be this thing right
here however as we've seen there could
be many y that are possible for a given
x right so
just by seeing x we can't tell
you know which of the y's is compatible
and that's why we introduce a latent
variable z
so this z right here is going to capture
all the information about why that isn't
directly in x
for example if we have a video of some
some car right the car
ah no
obviously
we have
the tracks
and they split right here
and they go right here and there's a
bunch of people and there is a person so
the trolley car problem
if we have the trolley car problem and
it goes down this is the video sequence
is up to here right
and we don't know how the lever is this
is hidden from us there are two possible
continuations one here one here the
we can't tell just from x x is here and
y is the continuation so
the variable z we introduce it to
capture that information in this case
the variable z is either left or right
it's binary variable and in order if we
have an x and we have a y
in order to compute that energy that
tells us how well the two are compatible
we need to minimize over z
so
what we need to do is if we have a
particular y let's say we actually have
the y where the card goes here right
so it goes on the lower track
we ask how well do these two video
sequences follow from one another well
the answer is they follow very well from
one another because certainly the card
going here is one possible continuation
and
that means that
we had to search over all the possible
futures which means we had to minimize
over z
so we considered z going up or z being
down
and we determined the z being down leads
to the lower energy and that is in fact
a very low energy now what happens if we
actually input a video sequence that
isn't
um
that isn't let's say we input a video
sequence instead of this
so the cart is here it goes here and
then
the next video sequence is of
i don't know like a teletubby
so there's a teletubbie it's a sequence
like
it's an episode from teletubbies
so these two things don't follow from
one another and again we do the same
thing we minimize over z
but
no matter whether we think the lever is
up or down uh as the minecart approaches
it never it's never a good continuation
that there is that follow the next
frames or an episode of teletubbies so
that's how you think about latent
variable energy-based models is that
there's a hidden variable the hidden
variable captures everything that is
sort of not captured in x about y
and we minimize over that latent
variable to get the actual energy which
means we're looking for the
the value of the latent variable that is
most that makes x and y most compatible
and
yeah so this is also going to be quite
powerful
which means that if we already know that
x and y
are compatible with one another then
minimizing over z if we have a good
energy function minimizing over z could
actually tell us something about the
latent structure of the world so we
could infer z or if we have this model
trained then if we have an x
we could actually sample some z values
in order to maybe produce different
future or different possibilities of why
this gives us a lot of freedom to handle
uncertainty in the world or simply
unobserved structure in the world
now there is a
problem with these types of architecture
and that is going to be collapse
if you've noticed that
we simply introduce this variable z
right here and we said well it contains
everything that's not contained in x but
there's actually no restriction for that
the if we train this model just with
let's say gradient descent and sum loss
and will make all of these variables
unrestricted then very quickly uh the
like the model will become
basically useless because
let's say our loss function is um
how well
we can predict from x and z how well we
can predict y right that's the general
form
now
we minimize
over
we minimize over the values of z
which means that if we simply set z
equals to y we can always perfectly
predict y
and that means x just becomes completely
useless and the prediction function just
becomes the identity function this is
known as collapse and
we don't want it
what we want to do is restrict z for
example so that like here it can only
take two particular values while x and y
are
sequences of video frames so that that
doesn't happen
or we can do it with some architectures
so let's look at different
configurations right here
of these energy-based models in any case
d here is the d is the energy or
the compatibility function
what if we have a deterministic encoder
that gives us the latent representation
of x
and then we use a predictor module
in order to predict y
so we'll just predict y directly then
compare it with the true y and then we
have a loss in between them this cannot
collapse because well
um
we need to predict the actual why
now let's introduce one of these latent
variables and we're in exactly the
situation that i just described again we
compute the representation for x but
we'll introduce this z that can vary
over a certain domain which gives us a
very a domain
that
we can control for the output of this
predictor right here
if we now try to predict y
from z and x we can as i said just set z
to y and we'd always be good so this can
collapse
what about this thing right here uh the
auto encoder
this
seems oh this is just the same as the
first architecture
this is the same as the first
architecture except
just y goes in so instead of x and y we
just have y it goes through an encoder
gets a latent representation goes
through a decoder that
gives you back the
gives you back an estimation of oneself
and as you know an autoencoder if you
don't restrict it somehow in the middle
here then it can just become the
identity function again and be useless
and the last one is this joint embedding
architecture now this
is looks or sounds an awful lot like the
thing that the paper is describing
and as you can see it can in fact
collapse so we're going to have an
encoder for x and an encoder for y these
could be the same but don't have to be
they're going to give us two latent
representations but
or then we use an energy function to
compute how well these two latent
representations fit together maybe with
the help of a latent variable
now
if
the encoders right here simply always
output the a constant vector
and this one does too and the constant
vector is in fact the same constant
vector then we're always good right we
always output the same vector and this
cost function up here will always say
yeah they're completely equal this is
completely cool they match together
super well so this can definitely
collapse and we need to do something
against it
this is
a
the main discussion here that leads us
into contrastive versus
restrictive or regularized architectures
and this is going to lead us to the
jia architecture
now it's going to be jepa but we're
building it up slowly
so how do we design the loss to prevent
collapse
now remember where we are we started
with self-super with we started with
recognizing that self-supervised
learning is probably a good thing
because we can do it without labels
right
we can handle multiple domains with this
all we need to do is we need to pretend
to not know some part of the input and
use the other part to predict something
about that unknown part we then said
okay we want to formulate this as an
energy based model where we'll obtain a
model that assigns a low energy to all
the compatible pairs of inputs and the
high energy to all the incompatible
pairs of inputs and that means at
inference time we can do a lot of things
for example minimize that energy in
order to find pairs that go really well
together or if we have a pair we can
we can look at the energy and judge how
well that fits
for example you could interpret
something like clip as an and simple
energy based model that simply computes
at inference time that energy and if you
view this uh vq gan plus clip
optimization procedures that were really
cool before dali was or mini dali was
open sourced
um then this is exactly minimizing an
energy at inference time so just so you
can imagine something below it we then
introduced
latent variables into the mix saying
well
for a given beginning of a video for
example there's going to be multiple
continuations and this could be captured
in a latent variable this could also be
for a given left side of the picture
there can be multiple right hand sides
and so on
this can be captured in latent variables
and to compute the energy we need to
minimize
we then discovered that this is probably
prone to a thing called collapse
among other things other arc like other
aspects of this architecture are also
prone to collapse and now we need to do
something against it there are two ways
of doing something against it there is
contrastive training or regularization
now contrastive training you might be
aware of that so on the left-hand side
you have the situation of like a
half-trained system so this half-train
system already has some training
examples that have a relatively low
energy but there are still some that
have a high energy so training means
that at the end we want to end up with a
model that assigns a low energy to
certainly all the training examples and
some space around it so we want the
energy at the low energy region to
extend to these training examples and
maybe cut out a bit from that middle
right here push the energy up a little
bit to say well actually
these samples in that space are not
compatible with one another
so contrastive methods are very very
classic method um
i don't actually know if clip is trained
as a contrastive
method but many many sort of of these
image
image
or self-supervised image training
procedures are certainly contrastive
what they'll do is they'll have an image
they are going to make two variations of
that image maybe by random cropping and
data augmentation and so on then they'll
take another image like a third image
from the database and they're going to
make also a variation of that and then
they use the embedding models
to embed all of those
i'm all ready so embed
embed
embed this into latent space so this
here would be your standard resnet
encoder or something like this
this is usually used in image
pre-training right and
oh no
so this will give you a data point
somewhere in high dimensional space and
then what you do is you try to pull
the two that are from the same image
together and you push
the
ones that are from different images
apart
this is contrastive training and it
relies on you coming up with these
negative samples
so what you want to do is you want to
create these contrastive samples that
you just kind of jiggle the data points
around a bit that you have in with um
using either augmentations or just some
sort of distortions and so on now
um what we've done right here is we've
chosen random negatives but we could
also actually mine hard negatives that
are very close to the training data
however this quickly runs into problems
as you know there's the curse of
dimensionality if you have a data point
and you want to wiggle it into different
directions those directions increase
exponentially as you go up in dimensions
so this whole approach of
finding training examples or finding
negative examples around a training
example to do the contrastive training
is
getting less and less tenable in the
higher you go with the dimensions and
therefore yonder advertises for
something different which he calls
regularized methods now regularized
methods have other means of restricting
that space
um that is low a low energy region so
there's no there are no constructed data
points outside here that you know make
the energy high here and low here
but
um there is a natural tendency of the
system like obviously you enforce you
enforce the system you encourage the
system to keep the
region where the energy is low very
small
and this is done through regularization
and we'll see how
um this is done in this
joint embedding predictive architecture
so this is the basic module we've
already seen it this was the thing
before that was um
no almost almost so this is almost the
same as before but again we have our x
and our y
two
points that we want to check if they're
compatible with one another we'll embed
both of them using deterministic
encoders this gives us latent
representations of x and y so x could be
the last state of the world y could be
the next state of the world so we map
these to the latent representations
then we'll use this predictor right here
to predict
the latent representation of y
from the latent representation of x okay
this is
the an important
part here that differentiates us from
before before we try to predict y
directly now we try to predict the
latent representation of y from x we're
going to make use of a latent variable
right here i guess this is optional but
it's built into this model right here so
this controls
which why or which latent representation
we're getting so z can vary over this
domain right here which then leads the
s of y this thing here to vary over this
squiggly domain right here so this
probably means that
z could vary over a relatively simple
domain but through the power of neural
networks this is going to be transformed
into some complicated manifold like as i
said does the current car turn left or
right gives rise to an in to an entirely
different
series of video frames and this
is then going into the energy function
whether or not the representation of y
is compatible with the predicted
representation of y
now since we are actually trying to
predict the representation this energy
function right here is probably very
simple like something like a cosine
distance or an l2 distance or something
like this that actually makes the
representations equal energies can be
much more
complicated but yeah
so here he repeats the main advantage of
japa is that it performs predictions in
representation space issuing the need to
predict every detail of why and enabling
an elimination of irrelevant details by
the encoders obviously that's also a
thing that's going to be subject to
collapse so he says you know these
encoders they could just throw away
everything that's not relevant about x
and y because we never need to predict
why directly
from something in here right we don't do
that so we can just forget about stuff
that is not important
now how why aren't we forgetting about
all the stuff
and here is where this regularization
comes in so how to train a model like
this
well
the first of all we obviously train it
by minimizing this predictive error
right here this is the basis right we
actually want to predict the latent
representation of y from
this thing or sorry from the latent
representation of x right we want to
predict this thing we actually need to
compute the loss between these two
things that's exactly this d function
right here this is the core right this
is unchanged from before however we have
a couple of regularizers here to prevent
collapse first of all
we regularize z
this thing right here what what do we do
we minimize the information content of z
and that means as before we said well
if we let z just be anything that we
want
given that we minimize over z at
inference time
this
z can just become equal to y
and make d
be zero all the time
so this is not good so we need to
minimize we need to regularize z
before i said z could just capture the
state of the lever
left or right right
then you know there is so much more
information in the latent representation
of the future video frames uh
that z cannot pass even if we minimize
over this binary variable cannot
possibly capture all of that so
restricting the domain of z is certainly
a way to regularize it we can also i
guess classically regularize it with
some l2 regularization we could quantize
it we could uh
apply sparsity regularization anything
like this that limits the z this latent
variable that we minimize over is
needed right here to prevent collapse
the other things that are needed are the
things that you see right here so these
are regularizers on the information
content of the latent representation
so what we want to do is we maximize the
information content that the latent
representation of the encoded
signal of the encoder perception has
about that
about that variable itself
well i guess it doesn't need to be
actually about that variable it simply
needs
it simply means we need to maximize the
information content of that variable
how are we going to achieve that there
are also various ways of maximizing the
information content essentially it just
means that
if that variable always has the same
value
it doesn't have much information inside
of it so what we can do for example we
can use a mini batch approach and have
many x right here x x1 x2 x3 x4 right
and these if these are all independent
we encode all of them we get a mini
batch of latent representations and we
can do something like we say well all of
these need to be different right and
they're for example
their covariance matrices must be
identity or something like this
so there are various ways and a lot of
young also points to some papers for
example
vic reg and barlow twins that have
already or can be framed in ways like
this but this is a general framework
minimize the information content of the
latent variable and maximize the
information content of the encoded
signals which makes sure that there
isn't a collapse this directly
counteracts that
down here i believe yeah exactly we have
vic reg as a system so
direct implementations of this you can
see right here the l2 loss between the
representations the regularization here
i don't exactly know how that's
regularized
doesn't
say here but
then the maximizing of the information
content here is or here of this thing is
done
via
via
regularizing the covariance matrix right
here
so
uh yeah
the last thing that he says here is that
we could also bias jetpa to learn useful
representations saying
it would be useful to have a way to bias
the system towards representations that
contain information relevant to a class
of tasks this can be done by adding
prediction heads that take
the latent representation as an input
and are trained to predict variables
that are easily derived from the data
and known to be relevant to the task so
now we're essentially going into the
domain of i don't know natural language
pre-training with with something like t5
or t0 where you just kind of throw tasks
at the system and hope and jointly train
all the tasks and hope that you know it
learns latent representations that are
kind of useful for language tasks
lacon says you could also in addition to
doing all of this you could also attach
some kind of a prediction head right
here and then have another loss
from a supervised signal or maybe a
imitation learning in reinforcement
learning or something like this
all of this
is entirely possible
because without it
without having these heads right you now
have a system that just sort of does an
information trade-off right it just kind
of trades off these these different
regularizers right here and tries to get
like as much information transmitted
through this path here about the latent
representation of y like it tries to
it tries to
counteract all of these regularizers it
tries to minimize the information right
here because then it can do a better job
it tries to maximize the information
content here as much as it can you
counteract it via regularization so
you're just kind of playing this
information game
with the variables right here and it is
up i would say to the designers of the
system to set the parameters on all of
these different loss terms correctly
such that the latent representations are
useful and i also think a big big big
part here is on the data itself like the
entirety of usefulness without
prediction heads of the system is just
down to the data right if you have data
if you want to learn something about
let's say
different chess positions like you want
to pre-train a chess computer with this
thing right you better input data that
has different chess positions
that differentiate themselves in the
relevant aspects of chess positions and
it's probably not a good idea
that you always have the same chest
position but you vary the sort of the
shades of gray in the chess board all
right so
this thing will sort of learn
what is
predictable
from the data that it gets so you better
make sure that that data the variation
in that data captures what you need to
get out of it
right so
what can we do with this we can arrange
it in a hierarchical fashion so this is
going to lead us to hierarchical japa
which is going to be the final the super
saiyan form right here of the model in
fact if you think about this going back
to the very beginning where we asked
ourselves how could we use a fully
differentiable system to plan ahead in
time well
if you consider this to be
you know your states of the world for
example or frames in a video or
something like this you could arrange
this system like we did are doing here
uh to predict over multiple time steps
right yeah as as we do right here so the
lower level predicts over short time
frames while the higher level you can
see
over here that this latent
representation is in fact obtained from
the latent representation of the lower
level by a second encoder and then makes
predictions over a longer period of time
so the hierarchical
arrangement of these things is entirely
possible and we can use that
to do
hierarchical planning so this goes back
to the very beginning
we at the beginning we saw how can we do
mode to planning if we have such a world
model right and now we're going to do
this in a hierarchical fashion
so what do we do
again say this is the state of the world
and we know at some point we have a
desired outcome like a cost function or
a reward or something like this well if
we have trained
such a multi-layer
predictive model in latent space
what we can do is
we can do what we did at the beginning
at this higher level right here so we're
just gonna do this thing up here first
which means that we're going to
ask this high level actor and we'll get
to what high level actions are but
assume there are high level actions for
example let's say i need to get to the
airport right the high level actions are
simply you know i'm gonna go out of the
house i'm gonna get in the car i'm gonna
drive to the airport and i'm going to
park the car there those are high level
actions and low level actions would be
the actual you know movements you do so
we can ask this high level actor to give
us high level actions we can roll out
the world model with it until we are
here we can use back propagation or
search or some other optimization
technique in order to refine these
actions as well as we can right
and then we
have here
targets for these low-level actions now
before these things on the lower level
were themselves kind of rewards that we
get from from the world but this is now
up here and the rewards on the lower
level are simply how well
we match those
um targets that are given by the higher
level so this this
action this high level action right here
could be get in the car right so now get
in the car becomes the target and we can
use our lower level planning algorithm
in order to determine the best actions
again using
proposals back propagation optimization
and so on to get in the car in fact we
can do it for all of these um to match
all of these higher level actions which
gives us entire action sequence that
would optimally fulfill
the plan to
to match these higher level actions and
you know if we're super duper engaged we
could also optimize all of the different
levels together until we have the
optimal sequence of lower level and
higher level actions in order to reach
this goal right here at that point we
can be relatively sure that this first
action right here will serve us just
well and we can actually send that to
the world get the next state and do it
all over again we can even use the
short-term memory or something like this
in order to
start at a better place for next time
already although the short-term memory
here is used to store
states in order to train the the train
the loss modules and the critics uh this
is if you are actually in an uncertain
environment you could even introduce
these latent variables right here
which you can infer so
if you want to reach a certain goal
right here you can infer the latent
variables
also through some sort of optimization
procedure or you can sample the latent
variables in order to give you different
continuations of your world model
up to you and there are various
possibilities that open up with these
with probabilistic world models
but i don't want to go too much into
this i think i hope you get the concept
by now of how to think about these
things again
this
we're again in the space where we have
the models trained and we need to do
inference time
inference time decision of what action
to take right training this thing is
a different game training this thing is
done via
this method oh sorry
this general method uh by
regularizing um by
minimizing the prediction error in the
latent space
okay i think that was it for the paper
the rest is about the rest of the
architecture designing and training the
actor
data streams designing the configurator
yeah this it gets a bit hand wavy at
that point i mainly wanted to bring
the um
i mainly wanted to bring
uh the the the japa architecture to you
and you hope you understand that
uh yeah so there's a bit of broader
relevance of the proposed approach
could this architecture be the basis of
basis of a model of animal intelligence
now it's the answer is maybe but i found
this paragraph here pretty
pretty astounding the presence of a cost
module that drives the behavior of the
agent by searching for optimal actions
suggests that autonomous intelligent
agents of the type proposed here will
inevitably possess the equivalent of
emotions
but that's that escalated quickly
in an analogous way to animal and humans
machine in emotions will be the product
of an intrinsic cost or the anticipation
of outcomes from a trainable critic
cool
could this be a path towards machine
common sense to which he says i
speculate that common sense may emerge
from learning world models that capture
the self-consistency and mutual
dependencies of observations in the
world
allowing an agent to fill in missing
information and detect violations of its
world model i mean this isn't entirely
possible uh it's certainly like a sense
of common sense like one aspect of
common sense uh
he makes another other few points saying
scaling is not enough mainly criticizing
kind of like you know can we just scale
up gpt3 in order to get intelligence uh
and to which he says probably not reward
is not enough which is sort of a
criticism of this thing of can we just
train reinforcement learning like
uh
to to to
you know
can we just train reinforcement learning
more and more to reach it and not only
is it
horribly
sample inefficient but also if it lacks
a
kind of a world model he also says it's
not enough yeah horribly extremely
sample inefficient so one aspect of the
paper is how do we learn
more efficiently
do we need symbols for reasoning this is
an interesting question and he says
maybe
as far as i understand it he says
probably at very high abstraction levels
uh these sort of latent variables or
states of the world might become so
discontinuous that it's essentially uh
symbolic at that point
at which point one could also use kind
of like tree search or so instead of a
back prop gradient descent yeah like
heuristic search methods including monte
carlo research or other gradient free
methods since things are so
discontinuous
so that is
it
a remain question a remaining question
is whether the type of reasoning
proposed here can encompass all forms of
reasoning that humans and animals are
capable of and that certainly is the
case
so this was the paper again
uh the core decor suggestion right here
is this
um
model or these types of models where you
have an energy based model the energy is
kind of like a cost function that you
attempt to minimize at inference time
you can use this for planning in an
actor by at inference time sort of
deciding what actions would maximize
that
reward or minimize that energy or
maximize the whatever um using your
world models in latent space right you
can do this hierarchically by starting
with the higher layers and
the higher determining
high level actions which are essentially
targets for the lower levels to match at
any stage you'll do inference
inference time optimization of the
action sequence
all of this can be trained
using
this uh arrangement right here where you
do train your predictor and your
encoders such that you can very well
predict the latent representation of a
part of the input this is
self-supervised learning from another
part of the input however in order for
this model to not collapse you need to
regularize the latent variable and you
need to regularize the information
content of the
latent representations that come out of
the encoder
lastly uh yeah i think i think that was
it
i hope you also got the idea behind the
difference between contrastive and
regularized methods contrastive methods
sort of try to generate data that is
goes well together and generate data
that doesn't um especially generate
these these negatives here
however due to the curse of
dimensionality that gets less and less
feasible as you go to higher dimensions
in your latent representations on the
other hand regularized methods don't
suffer this problem as much and
as we saw a regularizer can be put on
any height of of dimensional variables
now that was the wrong
graphic but
japa is exactly such a regularized
method and does not rely on contrastive
training
you can still do it obviously but it
doesn't it can be trained without
because it prevents collapse through
regularization
yeah i hope also it became clear kind of
what an energy function is and how to
use latent variables inside of energy
functions
and
this here no
this here still a bit of a mystery how
this all should work together but as i
said it's more of a position paper and
the vision
and i think the jetpac is the core piece
of this
paper so i hope you enjoyed this
leave a link to the paper let me know
what you think in the comments
and yeah i'll see you around bye